hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast make sure you subscribe
so you get the videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
lalalala
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find if they're going to be classy or if
they're just a big old piece of
triangles
trash
gotcha sucker try it again i'm your host
holy coming at you on a beautiful day
down here at auntie's basement being
mocked while i do the intro of course
he's my boss so i can't say anything
aunt hoody is upstairs knocked out
passed out hanging out went day drinking
yesterday yeah yep got roofied okay she
did it herself
drank it drank at home you roofied
yourself at a bus station and came home
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table yeah ceo of ru garbage got a
little bit of a five o'clock shadow
right now you did a little manscaping
you cleaned it up you got a little you
got you you made some uh some prem um
you made some things prominent i've seen
you yesterday though you did this
yesterday then yeah but
before you did this last night no i
didn't yeah you did no i did it probably
put on some springsteen shaving in the
mirror
[Laughter]
dang it's kj
hey gang happy to be here thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes even
though that don't [ __ ] matter anymore
full video available on youtube and
those numbers are true
and then i would like to uh take a
minute to thank the good folks um
over there
at the greatest website of all time
located at 600 towns and street suite
500 san francisco california 941 flowers
usa phone number
1-833-972-8766 patreon.com
send him an edible arrangement
buddy they're getting a christmas basket
for me that's all a couple of [ __ ]
sherry's berries let them know you care
we should send them a christmas bath 100
yeah [ __ ] flex though yeah thanks for
the thanks for the thanks for the
webpage we should slide in there and
blow both of them what are you talking
about hey nerds thanks for the coding
all right
holy [ __ ] and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the old magic man makes us all look good
the pride of the chicago comedy give it
up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
what up dudes what up tobias mike's off
launched it already thanks for coming in
just in your headphones stolen the
recording t-bone still on the board
very nice gang this is a family episode
we're already giddy we're already having
a good time uh we're here to answer your
questions as you know when you sign up
for patreon uh you'll get a question
read on the air yeah kj's people have
let me know there's a bit of a backlog
kj is a very busy man and we will get to
all of them sure and that is what we are
here to do
not gonna lie when we started this
podcast thought we were doing a bonus
episode
really no idea you don't know what's
going on i don't know what's going on
yeah i've i've equated to you're the
bear that i've trained
you know i've trained to ride the bike
and it's gonna [ __ ] snap one day on
me i'm gonna get [ __ ] you know one
day he's gonna eat you yeah yeah yeah
he's not gonna think i'm funny but
like a couple he's just gonna turn look
at me one day [ __ ] take a bite out of
my neck
if you did that
this sounds [ __ ] up but i would take
your teeth out what if i if i i would
never just have a bear he could have
upset a denture or something looks like
a dude
just get him regular teeth give him a
fighting chance hey bucy get over here
that'd be [ __ ] up but that's pretty
funny
a bear with regulations they've done
that they've
photoshopped it they've or given it to
dogs or stuff there's a there's a thing
on the online of animals with human
teeth
and also buscemi eyes was a big one
[Laughter]
nice cousin once removed
also i want to shout out at this current
moment i believe we're in the middle of
a merch drop it's a little pieced
together but go buy some [ __ ] merch
folks yeah check it out man some cool
shirts
and hoodies hot teas and hoodies and
undies right we could do a pair of these
pair of panties send you a pair of my
old sheets
throw the socks for free huh
give me these little piggy socks
you slide them off when you're on the
couch you're sitting there do your
little feet slide off the sockies they
typically come off early all like earl
my pants come off right away
the jeans i'm not yeah i'm not laying
down in jeans that's like you you know
you feel like a cowboys cowboy yeah i'm
not doing that
yeah jeans come off right away
you typically change the tee
i got an indoor tee that i rock really a
couple days a week you got a night shirt
yeah real soft [ __ ] ebenezer scrooge
over here
i was walking around
[Laughter]
i would have kicked those back in the
day for sure yeah yeah the long gown and
the [ __ ] and and the sleeping hat oh
man yeah
how cool you and your family all in the
same bed like willy wonka
all eating chocolate bars all head to
toe
how cold was it back then oh yeah
we're having a good time we are
also i'm glad to see the whole the
hawaiian uh or the palm tree shirts out
of rotation but this thing's this
thing's been bumped up in the rotation
making heavy appearances the past couple
had brought this kid up from the miners
last night yeah he's throwing heating
freeway trade with detroit
this thing ain't going anywhere not that
thing it's got a friend it's got a fresh
patty wash on it too yeah that's like
that's healthy
i mean fresh when you were down there
she did it on sunday
okay and i didn't wear it until yeah i
put it on for the first time yesterday
but when she does it i don't know what
it is it smells good for like a month
it's the menthols
she puts a little skull in every watch
sprinkles
chief support in there is that what it's
called chiefin yeah yeah chief in it
yeah
i like that it's the combo it's like
biscuits and gravy it's making a new
dish out of two things
it's interchangeable
it's like a super group yeah
one last big hit
right
yeah you are so it's interchange i'm
interchangeable but then change for once
will ya
[Laughter]
damn i feel like i'm doing a podcast
with a cartoon character i wish they
show i wish they stole double-sided
t-shirts that'd be awesome what like
it's brown on one side of black on the
other okay like a belt irreversible or
reversible irreversible
can't take it off what the [ __ ]
ah let's get into it we got a handful of
hot patreon questions to get to that's
what we love uh the homies as we call
them the homie shout out to the homies
um this one you know
we we play by the honor system over
there on patreon like we said we're all
homies you know what i mean so we play
by the we play by the honor code i say
hey let me know if you haven't had a
question right because there's thousands
of patreons i don't have like a [ __ ]
excel spreadsheet of going live i'd be
lying every time well this one is
in uh asterix haven't had a question
this is from sausage and peppers it's
haven't had a question read yet ever
lied and said you haven't had a question
read on ayg patreon discussion board in
order to increase your chances of
getting said question right on the
window or on the episode or just change
your patreon name
i i got i respect the hustle but come on
they're changing the patriot name is
psycho that's chess not checkers i'll
give you that you get me you get me i'm
hey if i'd like to go down at a good
ruse from time to time you know what i
mean call up and tell you their cousin
uh yeah that's pretty good i'll allow
that but on your system moving forward
folks honor system
look at you putting a stop to it huh um
yeah this is from nick i never have one
read
uh have you or anyone in your family
ever reposted the
the post on facebook to say repost this
and you'll receive richards in 24 hours
everybody's got an aunt who's in a chain
chain email well here's the thing back
in the day that was science not magic
sure you know five six years ago on
facebook that was the real deal there
was also something else if you tagged
three people or what was that one little
scam going they were all going around
tagged somebody you're tagged nine
people remember when people were
nominating people for [ __ ] what yeah
they were like the ice bucket challenge
oh yeah the ice bucket challenge that
was a nice good thing yeah
no money coming in from that though
you weren't seeing anything i did one of
those did you yeah
no you didn't i did it during the
pandemic yeah dude that's a great
question have you ever did you do the
ice bucket challenge yeah they raised a
lot of money
wait first of all the ice bucket
challenge was going on like a decade ago
not during the pandemic
what are you talking about maybe right
before the pandemic dude it was dude we
were doing the center city comedy
podcast at point break on 42nd 48th
street when the [ __ ] ice bucket
challenge was happening maybe it was the
warm water challenge
maybe my hot water heater was out
just being filmed taking a cold shower
what up facebook they just shut off my
gas
nine shares and uh maybe pico will turn
it back on
man you're a bizzo
yeah i've shared those uh i never did
but there's definitely family members in
my
immediate and extended family when you
go to their uh
their page
it's a lot of they still think it's like
black magic you know they just shared it
what facebook has become a mental
institution it's it's all of our parents
how are just running crazy on it they
came to the party and they [ __ ]
ruined it you know what's big my
[Laughter]
my stepdad's big on the
you know these heroes died for this
country 99 of people who see this won't
reshare it he just shares it like a
hundred times and i'm like this guy's
[ __ ]
i'm like dude these these numbers are
juiced all right
let me see the data that says 99 bed
people scroll right by this
thing i'm scared to share it i'll share
it
yeah it's a lot of like i'll prove you
wrong
it's a lot of my family's tonality on
facebook is come get it you know what i
mean
these colors don't run
you gotta do don't tread on me cover oh
yeah there's a dude grim reaper on a
harley meme yeah
it's cooking over there a lot of
punisher flags
yeah that facebook that gets wonky it
gets real on both sides of the both
sides of the aisle yeah yeah that
party's over well yeah
you know exchanging meds and stuff
they're all [ __ ] my mom doesn't even
she speaks in like broken english when
she makes a comment oh yeah beautiful
children lovely day
it's all sentence fragments
what the [ __ ]
sounds like a dumb robot
yeah nope she's got no picture yeah oh
yeah she stole the question mark
[Laughter]
[ __ ] carmen san diego over there yeah
that's real shifty they've never gotten
it and the parents just use it for
uh commenting on kids and sharing memes
that they think you know will save the
world
my dad looks up trains on it
too real cool guy
buddy buddy you gotta get over you gotta
see the [ __ ]
i caught him one day just watching
trains like local trains on youtube he's
like that's right over here
oh man
it's like look out the window
that's what they're doing on there man
it's crazy crazy yeah
it's nuts um that
not a lot of people in my family
understand bluetooth or streaming so
like anytime there's like a you know
we're all hanging out having drinks
because my family boozes i don't know if
you saw them in helium but they booze
pretty heavy
um and instead of just putting on like
it'll be like the younger kids like oh
we have you know like the like the
generation my age and even younger
like oh
we have spotify or pandora we'll throw
on you know the rolling stones or
classic rock and just let the channel
play and it's always like three uncles
passing back like a bootleg ipad
playing like one song at a time on
youtube and then like they can't find
you're just like go to sunset mix yeah
put on sunset mix and that's good you
know it's always bad when they're
yelling at the other guy what to type in
you know what i mean rolling stones give
me and you're like ah just [ __ ] it's
typically the third one down they put a
tv up in uh in my old bedroom it's a tv
that we keep in the sun room in the
summer and then bring it upstairs in the
winter
yeah you got seasonal tvs
that is no bueno when the patio is
closed what's the point
but uh it has it's smart tv and when
when you you know when you go to the
is it on one of those carts like when
you would watch a movie
in junior high they wheel it in
the av cart remember how heavy your like
regular tvs were dude i remember when i
would move out of place i was just like
i'm leaving the tv it's like keep the
sony yeah there was there was tvs i had
in college where you had to have another
guy
because you couldn't get your arms
around that two men
heavy well you throw steps in the mix
you're looking at a [ __ ] ankle ripper
but anyway it ha it has it has all the
apps there like just on it that if you
want if you're so if you have a
subscription you know how it works
yeah
she thought that hey i'm not looking at
trains over here she thought that she
was
don't let you told daddy
i love you buddy
uh she thinks that all the apps are
like all paid like
i didn't pay for them she said delete
that i didn't pay for that she thinks
she's getting screwed she's getting
screwed
i know it
my mom is flipping the cable out of the
wall
throwing the circuit breakers
cut the power to the mainframe i ain't
paying for roku
[Music]
what the hell is toby
get this off my mom's real big on that
if i
uh
when i'm home i'll like i'll rent a
movie i'll throw you know i'll throw all
like the five not like an on-demand
movie i do that now like it's nothing
which doesn't i did that
i'll still get they she still looks at
it like it's a life insurance policy
when it comes meanwhile she's still
paying for like aol and [ __ ] i'm like yo
tuts let's cut out the [ __ ] let's cut
the fat let me watch [ __ ] you know
the inside man or whatever
trying to get the town on yeah it's on
netflix right now
oh yeah it is uh
you know i didn't watch last night it's
not a bad piece of business the town
the the 18th time it ain't it's and it's
awesome oh it's great you can say the
irishman
no a great uh departed there's four
movies
american gangster oh come on
[ __ ] fantastic really i mean
obviously i've seen it before i'm not
bragging here but i threw that on last
night i was like i'll throw in something
slow
so i'll go to bed yeah i had to get up
early to move the [ __ ] car
00 am they got me yikes i rolled the
dice this morning i tried yeah i was at
a 7 30 spot said [ __ ] it came out no
ticket whoa
well 7 30 for me though it's take that
de blasio it's the tr it's for loading
for the supermarket and those guys they
if you're in their [ __ ] spot come 7
30. chase a cabbage on your own yeah and
you jam up the whole neighborhood
because now he's just there's a tractor
trailer in the lane block jamming
everything up
smash your windows out with a bad gun
like the fire department
[ __ ] yuka through your windshield
yeah
shout out to the yuca fry by the way
um
i keep you didn't like that no i'm not a
big yuca fry guy you're nuts
no pretty sane oh crazy uh
yeah
cubic is can take over right now all
right so if the cubans can take over
right now it'd be all right sandwiches
as long as they're coming
all right this one's from jack ah
bit of a dinger ever smoke a cig when
you're sick
[ __ ] yeah
and talk about hitting differently oh
dude there's always the thing too of
like shot at night cool and a bernie
sometimes you push it you're like i know
i shouldn't do this like or you either
wait too long like you wait and then
like the next day that one's great to
the first one back oh my first one
back's typically really good coming out
of this
when you start feeling better after
feeling sick you feel almost like super
human because you're going i'll never
feel just even neutrally like when
you're like really in a lot of pain
you're like yeah i would give anything
just to be able to you know just if
you're a forgot strep throat or whatever
i'd give anything to swallow and be able
to eat i remember like three or four
winters ago we had a really bad winter
and i went down to lansdale to do a show
i got super sick and ended up being laid
up in my parents house for like five
days downstairs in front of the
fireplace that i felt like [ __ ] clint
eastwood and unforgiven when i came out
of that [ __ ] had a blanket on me
walked out it was like snowing outside
had a smoke on the back
everything's going to be different
holy [ __ ] new lease on life yeah that's
that's sig it's some but it's like a
scab sometimes you go too quick and it
really jams you up if you peel it too
quick yeah yeah you're like
like that just set me back three days
you gotta have a bottle of robitussin
and some dayquil in you yeah yeah you'll
be swerving mm-hmm the dayquil always
oh yeah it's like yeah you're not sick
but it's like now i'm [ __ ] you know
i'm begging for change on the train
oh [ __ ] that thing moves quick you gotta
eat something with the nightclub
otherwise you're [ __ ] just cruising
hey gang as you know we are big fans of
helix over here at ayg and helix has
left the bedroom and started making
sofas uh called all form sofas all firm
sofas are fantastic um it's the easiest
way you can customize a sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores you pick your
fabric the color
the size the leg color the whole the
shape whatever you want they got they
have arm chairs love seats sectionals
the whole nine yards also it's delivered
directly to your door with fast free
shipping and if you know if you've ever
if you've been trying to buy a couch
during the pandemic
it takes months and months and months
for stuff to get delivered but not with
all four and they're sending it right to
you and if you get a sofa without even
trying it in the store sounds a little
risky but you don't need to worry
because you get a hundred days to decide
if you want to keep it or not
uh they were nice enough to send one to
us in the studio
and i put it together by myself in about
i don't know it's like 30 minutes the
whole thing just screws together snaps
in it's easy peasy all form is offering
20 off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
garbage one more time that's all form
dot com slash garbage for 20 off do it
it's the holiday seasons here let's talk
about manscape baby manscape just
launched new products including their
all-new
ultra premium body wash and two-in-one
shampoo and conditioner it's time to
give yourself or someone who needs it
the gift of beautiful skin hair and
balls this holiday season
also do not forget about the lawnmower
4.0 the electric trimmer
proprietary uh advanced skin safe
technology to reduce cuts on your own
nuts as you know i used to go
traditional blade and cream like an
[ __ ] but that's not it anymore they
sent us these packages and i swear to
god they are fantastic tis the season to
load up on manscape products so get
yourself your dad your brother your
friends the the best gift of all the
manscaped performance package 4.0 you
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code garbage at manscape.com
every guy out there needs to add
manscape to their wishlist this season
ladies get it for your guys guys get it
for yourself i'm telling you it's a game
changer you got 20 off and free shipping
with the
code garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use promo code garbage clean up your
nuts make sound and prep make santa
proud this year manscape.com promo code
garbage do it
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] good good
question um
this one is from adam new patreon first
question uh did or do your parents have
any religious commemorative plates
and if so of who
like the pope
or anything we have a lot of the
it's like that dir it's a dirty irish
[ __ ] like the irish blessing plate uh
you know yeah yeah yeah we have that
like we have that [ __ ] yeah we gotta
have all of that or like you know
something with like [ __ ] st patrick
on it we might have had a pope john paul
picture up somewhere back in the day
it was more of a pope sean paul
just give me the light
you don't know who sean paul is do you
no but i get the idea
[Laughter]
in my brain i just use shaggy
yo that word that works
that's who i cast
i got the picture give me a sean paul
type will ya
[Laughter]
put it up in backstage we need them oh
that's funny
nothing like that yeah no we had a lot
of we had a lot of crucifixes we had a
lot of palm palm was big it was always
like we'd put it like in above the door
above the door we would do like it would
like stick it in the corner of like a
yeah a picture or something like if they
would be like
hanging there right i hated going to
mass that was the only mess i went to or
not went to but like wanted to go to i
wanted to get my hands on that palm why
keep the demons away what do you mean
there wasn't one mass i looked forward
to going to oh they had they had me on
the superstition stuff pretty good
i
[Laughter]
knock away the bad guys
you're nuts chase the scaries yeah um
but yeah we never had like super overtly
religious stuff
i don't think
yeah no you know pictures of whatever
from time to time no altar or anything
like that no poor box
you go around you go around to those
baskets yeah checking everybody down for
some change that's like my mom says like
we'll be talking she's like i'll say a
prayer for whatever you know like i'll
say your prayer i've been praying they
maybe they've been working out let's let
them get it's always like i gotta eat
patty praying too everyone's praying
get patty get everything andrea get
everybody praying sometimes she goes to
me you should say a prayer i'm like you
know how far away i am from saying a
prayer lady it's a [ __ ] i mean he got
a better chance at me [ __ ] you know
praying to the devil
switch it up a little bit um
all right this one's from one two ever
go to a casino in the morning that's a
tough look
that i never thought about that but that
hit's different never well dude if
you're walking into a casino and it's
light out no
well there's eggs cooking
no
that's [ __ ] up you got a problem yeah
get out of there uh-huh that's like we
go we've been an ac a decent amount and
even that like just
the vibe of the the ten square blocks
around the casino
not a good hang on no it's not tough
it's people coming out people going
you're like
just getting there
you're not on a good trip if you're
arriving at eight in the morning sure i
guess it's one thing if you're checking
into the hotel for the weekend or
something i can kind of check into three
what are you doing early checking maybe
i don't know i'm just saying i can
relatively get that if you're like if
you flew to vegas
you land
it's light out you go check in you're
like oh i'm going to the table that's a
little more destination but if you're
just driving to if you're driving to a
casino and it's light out that's bad let
me ask you this are you an early
check-in guy
uh
it should be noon
yeah but then check out would be [ __ ]
9 a.m now it should be noon the next day
get 24 hours yeah but then how are
people gonna how can check in be at noon
and check out be at noon they have no
time to clean the rooms you bozo
it's to give them time to clean the
rooms
okay and then the second it's done it's
like three they should switch it then
check in at noon
check out at three
how's that work now you're there for 27
hours
and we're gonna split the room with the
guy for three hours
hey from new to three ted's coming in
tell the petersons to hit the ice
machine on the way up
grab a couple of towels yeah no
trust me i love it early i've tried
cracking the code a bunch i love it when
i'm checking out of the hotel i'm like
what the [ __ ] this is [ __ ] but
that's just the way it is
that it sucks but i mean most places are
eleven if you if you're if your checkout
of ten is that ten it [ __ ] sucks yeah
get your [ __ ] together figure out how to
clean the rooms from eleven or twelve to
three like what are we doing sometimes
you check in at like nine o'clock you
gotta you're checking out you've been in
the hotel for two [ __ ] hours
i don't like it i don't like it at all
yeah i like a noon checkout oh i always
ask for early check-in and i always ask
for late check-out yeah push it doesn't
hurt anybody no they want to throw 50 on
there throw 50 on there really yeah
you get the next couple hours get my
head on straight wake up take a nice
hour doing an early check-in when you
get to hawaii what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
have the plane drop me off there
i'll see you guys later
hey cap i want it
for the drop point i want to catch the
continental do me a favor [ __ ] db
cooper your way out of that swing by the
east side of the island will ya oh yeah
i'm already [ __ ] plotting that
yeah yeah what faking your death
i got the sunglasses on
i want to speak to the captain oh man
[Laughter]
hell yeah son get in as early as i can
and they're gonna drag me out of there
about to cut that wristband off my hand
yeah uh sneak back in grab a muffin
um this one's in the same vein uh and
we've talked about this before but
this has a new spin to it which all
right this is from this is from james
the drunken pierogies dolorsky
[Laughter]
do you put your toilet do you put
toiletries soap shampoo that you've
taken from hotels out for guests that
you're having overnight which is a very
that's a very classy thing
you've never used them right you didn't
take a squirt out no no you have them if
people are coming up because i just had
i just we just had guests uh we only
have one bathroom
i know but if you go there
i mean like i use a bar of soap i'm not
gonna be like hey buddy use this is that
what they used no i went out and bought
them i bought body wash and shampoo
so they have their own thing
okay but i'm saying if you have the
individual things of like oh here you
guys go this is perfect everything's
unused it's all perfect i can see that
you don't have to go make any purchases
that's fantastic i can see that but that
shampoo and conditioner from the hotel
always sucks i would much rather use the
good [ __ ] you got on the shelf that's
not true yeah it's not true they've
they've come a long way in the
in the tech in the where we shack you up
on the road yeah yeah you stay at the
red roof yeah especially when you get
lippy
i don't touch anything i hold my
fingerprints on that [ __ ]
you're over at the murder town
the place where the place they set us up
in philly they had long cone
yeah was was the stuff long comb what
was it called
l apostrophe cc
yeah what did i say i don't know it
sounded like long i thought long comb i
wasn't i didn't know what you were
talking i thought you meant a big a big
brush it was nice i was looking for that
this morning in my shaving kit get my
lotion on um because it's
chap season i started taking it for when
uh i just have a couple of them
for when we go to airbnbs because a lot
of times you go to an air b we don't
really stay at airbnb's anymore i like
it just having them little jaws in there
yeah soap yeah i'm agreeing with i'm
saying so i got them for when we go to
airbnb's of like okay i have fresh funny
can throw at the [ __ ] yeah it's like
here it's one or two uses for like the
night or two that you're there yeah
you're out the [ __ ] door it's
fantastic for that using it at the house
is a bad look though
i feel
maybe um but that's a very nice ti if
you go over someone's house to go oh
here's
brand new soap shampoo
lotion that's classic but they'll know
it's from a hotel yeah whatever but it's
your gut but also if that person doesn't
have anything or if they've been
traveling and they have like
i mean what are you going to use if you
go stay at someone's house
you're good like
i'm gross but i like using i like going
in and using their stuff yeah like if
you were coming over i would give you
your i would first of all take my stuff
out
out of the bathroom
why you got body wash in the fridge yeah
um
yeah i would hide it under the bed i
would keep keep it away from you i love
using other people's stuff no
especially if you're at a ladies place
that's the best that happened to you a
lot no
not now
it did for a little while
but now i got a shower at my place
yeah which i don't think you do that
frequently
um
yeah but i think that is a classy touch
if you're having guests over because you
just gotta it makes it a little more
nice for that's what i'm saying a little
more thought out of like oh here's this
yeah use your stuff if you want to use
their stuff but it's like we've thought
about that we've gone the extra mile my
mom was always good with that when
somebody came to visit it was nice the
house was spotless yeah put out fresh
towels for them
nice good time menu was going to be nice
next couple of days is it
what are we talking about
a couple casseroles a shepherd's pie
some cuddies
like that kid cuddy
um
all right let's see this one's from alan
ever seen your parent discipline someone
else's kid ever been disciplined by
someone else's parent
i was just talking about this not too
long ago cause uh talk about making you
feel weird dude it happened like i was
so it happened with my my we were at my
sister's house and the neighbors came
over
her the neighbors kids came over to play
with my
nephew like my nephew my niece and
nephew okay and they're older like he
might have been
six or seven at the time okay seven
let's call it and they might have been
like
it was like probably pre-junior high
like they weren't they you know but it
was like in the neighborhood so it's
like a tuesday night we're going to hang
out we're going to play football with
the kid across the street and they were
like probably 12 13. the neighbors kids
the neighbors kids so they were older
um the one kid was driving so
um his kids were there so they were they
were over and they were in a backyard on
the trampoline
and they were both kind of teaming up on
my nephew okay right of like
i think they were throwing the ball out
like they were playing the game but they
were just like it ended up with them
picking on him but also we come from
like a
bit of a tough love family he's like you
gotta
you gotta deal with that a little bit
you know what i mean like [ __ ] get up
and hit him or something that [ __ ] out
yeah do something buddy let's [ __ ]
start throwing hands over here what are
we doing
so
uh and then my mom
the one the one kid hit him in the face
with the ball
and we saw it out the window we're like
oh but it's also like i know you gotta
react to that a little bit you know what
i mean also it's not right for them to
be doing that but my mom wrote him like
oh that's different though that's that's
that's her grandchild
you get out of here oh really dude right
out the backyard she was like the
bouncer threw him out oh grip
kids knock that off don't do that he's
younger than you yeah we'll get your
hands off like like yeah it was dude me
and my brother were inside with our
[ __ ] hands and our faces like god
damn this bro cuckoo
she went out like she was just screaming
at these people she knocks them out like
step brothers
yeah it was a [ __ ] scene i thought
you meant more when you were a kid
if
um
your friend's dad would yell at you or
yell at him was even worse i saw how he
just had to sit there like a [ __ ]
jerk off
one time we snuck remember the kid that
we saw at the dallas game
remember the kid i ran to i grew up with
the dallas game vaguely anyway we one
time climbed up on his garage and his
dad came home all right and we knew his
dad his dad was like a coach whatever
but always really nice that was the
thing with those dads in the 80s and 90s
they were nice as [ __ ] but then when you
[ __ ] up that switch yeah their whole
week came out on youtube
it was their boss their nagging ass wife
you were getting it
you were getting [ __ ] you deserved it
dude it was usually once or twice
that was it oh yeah that's all you
needed you know what i mean i don't feel
like my niece and nephew or anybody's
scared of me at all but [ __ ] these
guys it was like [ __ ] once you
never again yeah you think about it to
this day it like post traumatic stress
from it
but we were up on the roof man and he
[ __ ] came home get down here right
now yeah and you always want to be like
yo was his idea jerk off it was your boy
like i didn't what like no he didn't
yell at me he [ __ ] screamed i know
but and when i'm sitting there i'm going
we're doing the same thing you're
yelling at him you're also vicariously
yelling at me of course yes but i want
to be like his fault like don't think
i'm the bad guy here this [ __ ] idiot
brought me up here it's not like i
pulled out the scaffolding and like got
up on the roof yeah let me talk to you
real quick i'm actually working
undercover
i've been taking notes i'll send you the
report i knew you was coming home that's
why i got him up there
this whole thing to set up you start
yelling at your friend
i'm 38 years old you didn't recognize me
his grades aren't that great either mr
wright look buddy you're gonna have to
hit me make it look real
yeah i remember that happened to me one
time uh i was at my boy vinnie with the
skinny's house and we were young and
we took uh his dad's hat like a tool
like it was like his hammer and we were
like [ __ ] around in the woods or
something
and i hit it on hammer in the woods is
no good
nothing good has ever come from that no
you're not building a homeless shelter
out there no
no it was yeah
and i hit it on something and it snapped
in half like it was like a
smaller one it wasn't like a [ __ ]
sledgehammer and i hid it on like a
piece of rock or something and it
snapped in here this is a good hammer
he [ __ ] i remember him yelling at me
and i want to be like bro
it's [ __ ] eight bucks what like i'll
[ __ ] who are you sure i would have
slapped the [ __ ] out of you but i
remember being like bruh what's that man
no i was just wanna be like
he was losing it on me because his
[ __ ] lifestyle was probably
sentimental to him i hadn't no it was
like a fight with his first hammer it
was difficult it was from like
heckingers it wasn't like this [ __ ]
old-timey thing
buddy chill out it's me the kip
don't blow a stack buddy
[Applause]
it's just a hammer bruh but i'm like
dude you're yelling at a [ __ ] i would
have knocked you out
i would have ran you over with a lawn
mower
what do you say
but i'm like dude it's a [ __ ] hammer
bro like i call my my dad i got him on
the house i'll replace it like what are
you i'm i'm eight years old and you're
screaming at me like i crashed your car
like what the [ __ ] it's a goddamn hammer
does this mean the yoohoos aren't coming
yeah i'm like dude get off my [ __ ]
case
god damn
yeah i think i looked in the eyes while
did it like it was a [ __ ] accident he
[ __ ] screamed at me i had another kid
a kid on my block my uncle mike was over
hold on parents got weird like i
understand your mom getting
getting like that because parents get
weird about that stuff and like there's
a very thin line yelling at somebody
else's kid is is real nowadays is real
dicey sure
sure you got you and that parent got to
be an and a real good you guys got to be
synced up well because like if it was
sorry if it was me and it was like
somebody like if like if i had a kid and
i wasn't there and he was doing
something wrong and you're like yo knock
that the [ __ ] off you know what i mean
yeah i would be you listen to your uncle
kevin yeah and we take turns working
them over
i have that because my our family's so
big to where like i can yell
at anybody regardless if i'm right or
wrong
it's
what did uncle kevin say
love that and it's it's not like hey but
you know we're you were used to allowed
to do this or something and it's like
regardless of what you typically do if
you typically play ball in the house or
whatever and i'm like hey guys take it
not that i do this but if i'm like yo
guys take it outside and they'd be like
no mo our mom lets us play full-time
bartender
look at that side hey mind your p's and
q's boys um and i'm like hey guys go
outside and they're like oh we typically
play here first the dad or someone will
step in and go do not talk back to uncle
kevin and also listen to him like that's
a that's a that's an adult you have
absolutely anybody can get god at any
time that's too much power
i don't i mean first of all i don't care
i'm the one i trust the family i'm still
playing steady qb in the family room
i'll tell you what happens is kids that
that doesn't happen too they're going to
be [ __ ] bozos
you got to listen to the adults that was
the biggest thing but adult told you
something you did it yeah
that's how most of us got hemmed up but
yeah
[Laughter]
but my uncle the one time he came up and
now i'm looking he was probably younger
than me he was probably in his 20s this
was
i mean it's thirties it was 20 something
years ago
he came up to our house he was staying
with us for like the night or something
like visiting my my my parents or my mom
and
he uh there was a kid on the block
ryan bad ass kid that's great badass kid
like just not like like bad ass not like
cool just like rude bit rotten kid yeah
bad bad seed
bad scene that's a kid who's whose
uncles aren't allowed to yell at him
sure and he said he tell him what to do
he told my uncle teach them things [ __ ]
off or whatever what something he cursed
and on the couch uncle with nothing to
lose it was a real real toby vibes if
you catch my drift we're a long-haired
bozo
yeah this kid rules yeah uh
and he said something like go [ __ ]
yourself or this [ __ ] stinks or
that's not [ __ ] fair or something he
was like seven and i was younger i was
like five i remember my uncle grab was
like get out of here just like [ __ ]
kick rocks kid game over go home i don't
care who you are you're not staying here
i don't like to get the kick the kick
and the kick in them out
you try to teach them no you don't want
to act also why why the [ __ ] does my
uncle care what some guy on my block's
doing he's just going dude i'm leaving
at noon get out of here i don't want to
[ __ ] deal with you it's not his joke
dude if a seven-year-old's telling a
grown man to go [ __ ] himself
there's no work my uncle's gonna do in
three minutes to cure that kid
uh i got you makes sense yeah
i think
i remember
not being yelled at but i remember like
another adult like tried to like they
were going to the beach but my parents
weren't going to the beach and he's like
i got him come on it's okay he can come
to get us my mom was real sketchy about
that [ __ ] we were kids that's where i
get my fear from you you're what do you
mean your fear don't go in the ocean
don't get kidnapped don't do you know
what i mean all that stuff i got the
patty's got the spider sense for that
yeah it's [ __ ] called repressed
catholic guilt that's what that's called
think the [ __ ] you think there's some
evil spirit gonna come down and strike
you that's how we like it and i love you
patty
um
but no and then he was like no it's fine
i'm like no you're not taking my kids to
that age when i'm not there made it real
awkward oh real cool
who's there with our boogie boards and
her hands like all right
but i see where she's what if the
cicadas come what are you gonna do then
i see where she was coming from you know
because sometimes the parents overstep
especially it's probably a minefield now
to be honest with you
having kids now and dealing with that
[ __ ]
uh like if a coach yells at a kid the
parents will be calling up like
yeah yeah yeah that happens a lot yeah
no good
hey but you know you gotta learn that's
why i could never go back and
take the mantle up what coaching
one you don't have any kids that'd be
[ __ ] weird if you just showed up and
was like hey i'm gonna wear the same
shirt every day all season and yell at
your kids
okay nobody would want you around first
fundraiser tomorrow night yeah 100 plate
dinner
and listen uh you want to play it's one
candy bar per game you got to give me
you got to pay up pay your dues kids you
pack two lunches two lunches
[Laughter]
we talked about that peanut butter and
honey [ __ ] either
we're talking about black buffalo baby
black buffalo is a high quality tobacco
alternative if you're 21 and over and
you dip or chew tobacco pouches are long
cut you have to try this tobacco
alternative black buffalo it's
everything you love
about dipping including the
pharmaceutical grade nicotine just
without the actual tobacco leaf or stems
best part about it born in the usa baby
born in the midwest raised in the south
black buffalo proudly manufactures the
products in the united states of america
they sent us some
as you know i'm a burning man but i gave
this stuff a whirl it's top-notch you
know so if uh you are one of the 10
million people who are 21 and over in
dip tobacco
you dip tobacco consider making the
switch to black buffalo it's everything
you love about dipping just without the
actual tobacco le4 stem head to
blackbuffalo.com use promo code garbage
at checkout for 25 off your first order
that's the best offer you'll find out
there but you have to use our code
garbage for 25 off your order one last
time that's promo code garbage for 25
off your order warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine as an
addictive chemical dad grass dad grass
dad grass dad grass baby we're talking
bad grass uh as you get older have you
ever been just too high
that's what that grass is here to
prevent uh we've all been there with
today's weed sometimes it's dangerous
game you're rolling the dice that grass
is reviving the pleasure of the casual
smoke so you can chill out without the
stress
dad grass is legal organic smokable hemp
that relaxes your body and mellows your
mind there are 100 organic pre-rolled
joints that are very low in thc and high
in cbd so you can enjoy the effects of
cbd while keeping your head clear you
can chill out without getting stoned
it's like having a glass of wine not the
whole bottle just take the edge off a
little bit as you guys know we're big
cbd guys they sent them to us fully the
big man can't get enough of this stuff
so whether you're looking for a new buzz
or a chill way to enjoy an old favorite
that grass will leave you in a euphoric
mood
right now dadgrass is offering our
listeners 20 off your first order when
you go to dadgrass.com garbage go to
dadgrass.com garbage for 20 off your
first order one more time write it down
tell a friend whatever you got to do
that's dadgrass.com garbage now back to
the show
that's a thing for you you could go back
and like coach he has to be a teacher i
think
yeah cause i don't know anything about
graduated high school
i don't know anything about the sports
that i played but where i would be able
to be in the know of that
it's teaching all the kids you're
[ __ ] psychotic fears that you have
[Laughter]
never look a dog in the eye he's going
to steal your soul
you [ __ ] wacko
if you have a bad thought hop on your
left foot eight times in a row it'll
cancel it out i didn't call your mom
until you love her
bad news is i don't know anything about
water polo
nor can i swim
now get in there boys
[Laughter]
we're down 12. there's two minutes left
i think
somebody say a prayer
[ __ ]
what do you guys think we should do who
who here knows the rosary
[Laughter]
[Music]
showing up to the game on the wrong days
i thought it was tuesday yeah
i thought we were doing a patreon game
god damn
home run of a question home run home run
home run that's what it's all about
that's what it's all about um
this one we've never we've talked a lot
about the trash can trash bags that
whole nine yards we've never thought
about this did your family take the
trash this is from scott i apologize did
your family take the trash bag out of
the can and leave it on the floor in
order to fill it max capacity
oh yeah of course so you just let it sit
there and then you can continue to stuff
the worst of course yeah that's a if you
were cleaning up from dinner and it was
full you know take it out and
get this all [ __ ] get all the [ __ ] out
of there yeah and then take the trash
out yeah this seems more of like uh
i don't feel like taking it out so i'm
just gonna place it next to here is that
something i've done that
what was that did you hear that
fully did it was my phone now
god damn it you're
you two [ __ ] chirping back and forth
yeah we have to communicate he's the
producer of the show
hand signals how do you guys feel about
the the extra empty bag in the bottom of
the trash can i love it that's
trash no it's fantastic yeah my mom does
that that's like janitor stuff
that's what
yeah that's great i know your mom worked
at the airport
yeah that's genius that's really good
yeah big fan of that you don't like it
no i love it every time i remember to do
it i'm like yo shout out past me yeah
how'd you feel about this growing up
stumble across somebody's house who had
a trash compactor
yeah my aunts got one they never worked
oh no my aunt always has really yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah compress it down and
then where's the bag go what do you mean
does the bag come up with it
is the is it in a bag yeah you there's
like a special bat you can't just use
like a [ __ ] hefty bag oh you gotta
come back to back so like it's it goes
around the thing and stays there and
then that just pushes the trash down
and then when you're done you just get
trash i never trusted them are they
gonna steal your wallet what do you mean
you never trusted them
oh i never thought they worked but they
were cool for a second when you saw them
yeah
mm-hmm that would yeah that if somebody
had the water thing
thing attached to the to the faucet the
filter the big egg looking yeah by moan
or whatever whatever that thing yeah i
didn't really trust that though i was
like this thing is dirty now i get to
not trust in it there was always like
pasta sauce on it or something it was
never like a straight shooter yeah
nobody was changing the [ __ ] filters
on those things no
and i think the only people
we never had more black mold please
it was also one of those things where
i'm like why don't you trust the water
what's going on around here that you
don't trust the sink you know what i
mean like i don't trust this thing it
was always in wonky houses no
none of like my
good friends had one
it was always like you go over some
kid's house it was like you know good at
skateboarding or something his his dad
was gone for a while yeah and they had
one like toothpaste yeah like where the
[ __ ] is going on here yeah i'll take a
gatorade buddy
what do you got in a can
he's got something hermetically sealed
the draft situation um that's a great
one um this one this is just funny this
is from jay uh our boy jay from rhode
island the kid that was love your buddy
yeah yeah he's on twitter a bunch love
him he had the fantastic question about
smoking cigs or taking the cigs out of
the trash
um
it just says you ever wear a
g-unit-style wife-beater or a shirt do
you know the g-unit do you know them
this might be too deep of a cut are you
talking about just like a talty no that
it's specifically uh the wife beater
i'll pull one up um
i had a feeling you weren't gonna get it
uh
it's one of these these are a bad look
they're like
kind of like european cut like those
wife beaters with the big just like mx
yeah like unit life beater no
it's it's cut like a bulletproof vest
yes yes it's very like tactical
you see it there was like you gotta have
some pecks to pull dude oh yeah it's
like a sports bra on top yeah those are
it's typically not great guys wearing
those i had a couple of buddies try to
wear them in like college when they
dropped and you're like dude you do not
fill that thing out
no those things are scary yeah i don't
like that wife beaters all around i i
never do never did once for like i had
like two or three of them
and i looked like a sausage yeah i tried
to go i tried to do it can't do it
um
all right let's see here this is from tj
have you ever shown up to work in a
walking boot or on crutches
the walking boots are big now
remember we saw the [ __ ] i feel like
i feel like
every week i see at least one
attractive girl wearing a a
a boot i i know that sounds weird
yeah it's always a young pretty girl
wearing a
walking boot yeah we saw them in austin
remember there was a there was a [ __ ]
it was like the mutants at table nine it
was a bachelorette party and there was
like one girl with a cane another girl
in a walking boot the one girl was in a
sling you're like what they're like hey
already you named tim and you're like
get out of here that was in austin yeah
i don't remember that okay i was there
for that yeah we also saw the chick in
houston because they got the scooter now
with the boot that's a tough look where
the knee scooter yeah yeah except that
one chick at the at the cowboys game was
cooking down the oh yeah she was riding
like it was the [ __ ] pinewood derby
apron whisk
again and it cub scout's paying for this
yeah
that thing was yeah she was yeah she was
really going i was like lewis hamilton
she was giggling too you could tell she
was like this is sucked until right now
yeah that means you got good insurance
though you get those things
why are you healing so much i like
looking i'm like oh my god are you okay
like yeah i rolled my ankle drunk or
whatever you know it makes it seem way
more oh yeah permanent or like way more
serious than
you know i've you know tore a ligament
in my ankle yeah
but the boots i would just never boots
look trashy and i get they go yeah you
don't need crutches anymore and i think
crutches actually
end up causing there's a thing where
like crutches cause more issues or
something i could never do crutches
doesn't surprise me it's like riding the
bike with the with the no hands right in
the tent speed with no hands i could
never do it i could never walk on
crutches i always thought it was
cool people were cool that could walk on
crutches you always wanted something
back and you're like i would like almost
fall over i would like be a blue and
like almost fall back
i cannot even start to wrap my head
around that at all
what didn't you
i would put them both down and i would
go up and my feet would be off the
ground
yeah that's the point
no it's suppose you're supposed to be
one
no you don't i didn't know how to use
them
i never learned how to use crutches all
right the fact that you did this
oh my god cross country skiing yeah
you're going one at a time that's i i
could never get it yeah
well
man you are something else
but i think the boots the boots are just
sloppy i'd rather see you on crutches
because i go oh that's whenever i see
one of them i assume you got drunk at a
bar and fell over that's what i assume
when i see when i see a chick wearing
those yeah but it's even anybody but
they're like big and you're like i never
see dudes wearing them really yeah well
get out more hit the saunas or something
check out the steam rooms
see what the boys are up to uh i don't
hate it
all right this one's from ruben mussack
i never had a question read this i don't
know if we've ever talked about it ever
gone to an open house just so you could
walk through your neighbor's house
no but we talked about just going to
open houses with no intention on buying
sure but your neighbor's house is that's
another level very interesting i never
thought my mom's big on that my mom goes
to multiple open houses in our
neighborhood just to see
like how the people lived or what the
place looks like
yeah she loves that stuff i don't know
oh they had the bedroom downstairs i
feel like you'll hear about it for like
two weeks really i went over to the
johnsons yeah you'll never guess what
they did
yeah
i think
i don't know i think because we rent
obviously and like most apartments tend
to be a little more i feel like
apartments are a little more sterile we
were talking about this yesterday i i
take when someone opens the door i take
a peek yeah i want to see what they got
my main thing is like i don't know if
the house can ever really shake its
smell like if a family was living there
like if we moved out of my mom's house
every house has a smell you know like
your house is always gonna for the next
20 years if you redid it i mean you have
to redo everything we're talking all the
carpets that's in the walls that's
there's no carpet in our house yikes oh
you dexter
what the [ __ ] it's all hard wood baby
all right that's a little whatever but
i'm just saying it's like that's in that
wood dude that's years of foley farts
and
you know just the bernies the
tomatoes cutlets yeah that's all that's
what i'm saying that's just in irish
spaghetti where i feel like an
apartment's like a little more short
come and go it's like an airbnb yeah but
if you're living in a house for 25 all
that everything
apartment's smaller too when we get in
there
you know they clean it we blast it out
what i like to re-establish my scent in
there when you first move into a place
oh yeah you gotta go around rubbing your
ass on [ __ ] like a cat
absolutely
first thing i do take a dump right in
the kitchen
[Laughter]
burn a cheesesteak
[Laughter]
now we're home baby get out of here for
a couple hours i gotta make this place
ours yeah mark that's always i always
worried about that of like i would a
house i buy would have to pass the
schmidt like
oh of course smells important
yeah of course you're not gonna win
it's my ploy to get you to shower more
smell is very important
you're not buying you're not [ __ ]
paying a mortgage every month the place
smells like soup i know
i know i'm just saying
but that's what i'm saying you walk into
your dream house and you're like ooh
just got a tinge of hoarder in it or
something yeah
yeah a little bit of this is real
goulashi yeah oh yeah now
that's what i'm saying real cabbage vibe
and it's just not even
like
you know take like any of my boys like
any of my friends houses growing up they
had a distinct smell oh this is not bad
of course no yes but i'm saying if i
walked into good usually they were you
knew you were walking into the o'brien's
yeah but that's conditioned you know
what i'm saying like sure your condition
go oh i'm here to have a good time it's
friends it's family it's chicken cutlets
you're conditioned to be like this smell
is a good thing
right but i'm just saying like if i
walked into i had that with my boy paul
his mom kept a tight house and it was
always remodeled and light and airy and
good light fresh and i don't know i've
i always wanted to ask him but she used
some kind of detergent where like they
all smelled like that
and they were like you know they were
very attractive family young family they
were very cool so i used to love that
but walking in any time i ever smell
that it instantly takes me there
yeah you're a weird guy you know
what i've never heard someone ago i just
wanted to share i love how that family
smell it just
it was a glimpse into like how your
brain works for me it's exactly what
you're talking about like when you walk
into a house you recognize the smell
that's all
i was watching them shower or anything
like that
no never
oh
no i'm just saying there was a good vibe
in there that's all i'm saying and i'm
not saying it in a bad way i'm just how
you connect
things things to your past specifically
sure of that like i understand what
you're saying like when i walk into the
studs place i'm like this is a stutz's
house we're gonna have [ __ ] aldo's
pizza and a couple of pops and you know
whatever
that's great i have that feeling as well
but i'm just saying to like i would i
don't know just see
you in the moment of like you really you
did reminisce about getting yelled at by
someone else's dad i mean like yeah
that's how it was back then it was
different gave me ptsd in the same
breath yeah yeah
yeah you're a little cuckoo banana well
my nostalgia is triggered by my sense of
smell yeah then what i'm trying to say
is you're very nostalgic yeah that's
what that's what i'm saying yeah that
was that was the main thing of like i
like the way it was and then sometimes
you go like i just regular joe could
walk down the street
[Laughter]
i really like how to thompson
that's what like even that's nostalgic
for you is what i'm trying to say
i've never been like oh this dudsky's
love them you know what i mean like
i don't know if it was tied or what
that's what i'm saying like i've been
like oh i love the times i've had
there's like a crisp linen smell that's
what i'm saying i've loved the times
i've had the laughs i've had you i
enjoyed this you go to the detergent
smell of the family
no human interaction just i really like
the lemon scent pledge she chose ooh
love a lemon pledge love those
commercials my mom was oh i love
cleaning product commercials especially
when you're home and you're sick
my mommy shoes pine sauce loved it every
80s and everybody used pine saw all
right sorry yeah
okay not to riley's
not dorado's
um
all right let's see here let's do a
couple more um
[Laughter]
and
ah
let's see
we've talked about this i think but this
is their first question uh probably
probably talked about a long time ago do
you or anyone you know have the back
seat or seats of an old car on the floor
of your garage as furniture to chill on
we had the back of my step-dad suburban
and i thought it was just a seat that
you took out yeah
but you could put it back in he stole
the car yeah yeah and i just so wanted
it in my room so bad to be like
everybody come on kippy's got car seats
it was it reminded me of the seinfeld
you're sitting there with the seat belt
on
i'm in a booster seat
it reminded me of [ __ ] seinfeld
because he had the back of the cramer
yeah kramer had the back of like the
deville or whatever never got a full
look at kramer's apartment no pretty
sweet though yeah you see they they
recently came out and said like they did
like uh the schematics of jerry's and it
could never exist that wouldn't work
because it would be in the like the
kitchen would be in the hallway or
something yeah it never just never
worked it's pretty devastating
i'm never
[Laughter]
yeah
all right now
all right well i have to pull one more i
mean we've ran through like 20 [ __ ]
questions we're back one sec we're gonna
have to edit this out cutting all this
out
let's just do one more and we'll wrap it
up
all right let's do one more and wrap it
up
hold on let me get it first i was just
doing it for a clean take
all right let's do one more and wrap it
up
all right
[Laughter]
all right this one's from alan shields
uh i have not had one read yet this is
bonkos have you ever have you ever had a
family birthday party in a mall food
court this would include decorating the
table and possibly bringing a cake
singing of happy birthday is included in
this celebration
oh my god that's
sad
yeah what are you getting too i would
give what are you getting is everybody
lo mane and a burrito
that's pretty good then i'll give you
that everybody gets that's a lockhart
that's not a bad idea
can you set that up though no
everybody have to be standing in line
someone has to be watching the table
yeah i wonder if you could set that up
with the mall that's actually not a bad
idea but that's pretty siana you can't
set that up dude you can't the mall food
court is lawless that's international
waters no one's overseeing that i would
give them everything i got at the mall
if i walked by and saw that here you go
yeah that's tough yeah that's a bad look
butt
egg roll with a candle in it
the thing that is the thing that's the
worst orange julius that's a tough look
that's a tough look nobody cleans those
tables either oh man
i just smell the oxford valley mall i'd
get some borrows for sure which by the
way ain't a bad slice you can't have a
birthday party where the chairs are
bolted down it's true where's your mom
yeah i didn't get that that's like
[ __ ] that's like cell block d
what are you going to rikers
chairs aren't bolted down um not at the
plymouth medium while i was just there
uh the thing that makes it the worst is
um
the decorating if everybody was like yo
i think it'll be fun and kitschy if we
all go get our own sticks and we'll sit
there and have fun like as a teenager
you'd be like oh let's all go do this
this will be fun and kitschy whatever
why the food court
maybe because there's like an arcade you
hit the arcade laser tag go see a movie
you wouldn't do that in the arcade there
would be a dave and buster's in there
yeah or like something of like with the
proper private room to conduct a
birthday evenly a lot of them would have
like the private room of like for the
birthday party i feel like the kid would
know that too like oh this sucks yeah he
knows it he's sitting next to a [ __ ]
business man eating [ __ ] fried rice
he's watching a kid walk out of a toys r
us with better gifts yeah exactly look
at all the families that love their kids
[Laughter]
what did you get for your would you give
me your birthday 20 minutes in the
massage chair
yeah i got to walk around brookstone for
a couple of minutes
the remote control cars
i got that raccoon tail in the bag of
chips
[Laughter]
all right let's wrap it up gang listen
we love you uh thank you for all the
love all the support kippy what do you
got for him uh got some tickies coming
up you got hartford you got albany
hartford albany syracuse uh grab some
[ __ ] merch i'm at kevin ryan comedy
and all social media also follow the ayg
pages at ru garbage on twitter and
instagram we love you we'll see you next
week